[Music]
jellyfish are some of the most dangerous
creatures in the ocean
just touching the wrong one can lead to
a swift death
and now these people are swimming with
millions of them but how
and what would happen if you chose to
swim with
millions of jellyfish what does a
jellyfish sting feel like
is it possible to swim with them and
live to tell the tale
[Music]
and can peeing on a sting really save
your life
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you fell into a pool full of
jellyfish
the jellyfish's venomous sting is
extremely dangerous
just brushing against a jellyfish can
result in incredible pain
their stings harm over 150
million people each year if
you were to jump into a pool full of
jellyfish
is there any way you could avoid their
deadly stings
[Music]
as soon as you jumped into the pool full
of jellyfish
you'd immediately want to check your
surroundings to see what you're dealing
with
jellyfish come in all shapes and sizes
they range from the lion's mane
jellyfish that's longer than a blue
whale
to the moon jellyfish that's just five
centimeters long
kind of cute many of the jellyfish you
might experience here
would move with the current of the water
after
all jellyfish don't have brains so they
don't have much control over their
movement
but some species like the box jellyfish
are much more dangerous
these jellyfish are different as they
hunt their prey
but regardless of whether or not this
jellyfish is hunting you
jumping into a pool full of thousands of
them would
definitely end up with you getting stung
and
if you get stung regardless of the type
of jellyfish
you would immediately feel a burning or
pricking sensation
this sting would eventually turn purple
then start to itch and swell over time
the pain would spread beyond the sting
site and reach
other parts of your body but if this is
all that happened
you'd be pretty lucky at this point you
could get out of the pool
remove the tentacles from your skin and
the sting would
heal itself over time you might need
some painkillers but
overall you'd survive and no
don't try to pee on it the water and
sodium in your urine
can agitate the stinger causing it to
spread even more venom
but you ending up with just a little
sting is
incredibly unlikely in this scenario
especially if you're swimming with boxed
jellyfish
their sting wouldn't just bring you some
pain and irritation
if you were swimming and happen to be
stung by one of these
it could make you feel weak drowsy
and you might even start to have muscle
spasms
this could easily cause you to drown and
if
more jellyfish came to sting you you'd
be feeling incredible pain
all over your body someone else would
need to pull you out of the water as
you'd most likely pass out at this point
and
as soon as you got out of the pool you'd
need to immediately get
anti-venom in your system that's because
a box jellyfish sting
releases a venom that can stop your
heart in as little
as 5 minutes and if you didn't get the
anti-venom in time
you could die so it's safe to say that
swimming with jellyfish could be
incredibly dangerous
but this isn't the only way swimming
with jellyfish has to end up
there's a place in palau known as
jellyfish lake
that has hundreds of thousands of golden
jellyfish swimming about
this species is completely safe to swim
with
as their sting is so mild you might not
even notice it
so if you happen to fall into this lake
with all these jellyfish
you'd be completely fine in fact it
would be a beautiful and
breathtaking experience
another experience that might take your
breath away literally
would be swimming in a pool full of
sharks
but we'll leave that story for another
what if